muss gehen oder muss verschwinden oder
muss zum
liebe wort musik und müsse die
silhouette
der liebe gott soll putin zu sich holen
über diesen satz sprechen wir gleich mit
paul ronzheimer in kiew und auch darüber
endlich fährt kanzler olaf scholz in die
ukraine noch in diesem monat zusammen
mit dem französischen präsidenten
emanuel magna und dem italienischen
ministerpräsidenten
mario draghi dieser besuch überfällig er
wolle nicht nur für ein foto nach kiew
reisen sagte scholz immer mit leeren
händen kann er dort also nicht
auftauchen die erwartungen sind groß
hier in den trümmern von kiel in der
stadt die im fadenkreuz der russen steht
vor den ruinen einer von russland
zerstörten
eisenbahnwaggon fabrik trifft bild
exklusiv die klitschko brüder mit einer
nachricht aus deutschland
der bundeskanzler kommt der
bürgermeister kirsch hat an ihn eine
klare forderung der
unterstützungsmission war
sein bruder wladimir bringt es auf den
punkt was scholz zwingend mitbringen
muss mit allem zeug waffen kommentars
hilfe finanzielle hilfe um so hat klare
worte an olaf scholz der krieg geht
indes weiter im osten der ukraine im don
was steht der russe kurz davor die
region einzunehmen nach
bild-informationen geht den ukrainern im
donbass die munition aus vitali
klitschko kann nun das wiederholen was
die brüder schon seit anfang des krieges
unzählige male gefordert haben
berufssoldaten berufung hat mehr
ergriffen deswegen will braucht dringend
unterstützung
weil ich möchte noch einmal betonen ich
noch einmal wiederholen zu ihrer führung
währte da die gerichte unserer städte
und seine familie um unser land wir
verteidigen auch bewährte was raten sie
jeder demokratischen europäischen doch
was passiert wenn diese waffen nicht
geliefert werden was heißt das für die
ukraine
das bedeutet noch mehr
zu helfen wir sterben die kämpfen gibt
einfache war vom gegen moderne waffen
was das berufs- und will muss und wir
mussten uns beteiligen beteiligung
soldaten für das land und das das so
wichtig heute eine moderne schwere
waffen zu bekommen ich würde mal wieder
und beteiligungs war wie gracias a dios
war sven olaf scholz erneut zögert kann
das den verlust von land und zahlreichen
menschen leben bedeuten doch die
auswirkungen wären nach wladimir
klitschko um einiges größer es ist
wichtig zu verstehen wenn wir fallen
fällt ihr auch wir sind in einem
ökosystem wie sie es für wohnen
miteinander
frieden demokratie die sich schöne welt
was beschrieben wird wird hier zu
starten zu können und wie gesagt wenn
wir vor allem werdet auch ihr fallen es
geht für die ukraine um alles
der bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat die
macht den ausgang dieses sinnlosen
krieges zu beeinflussen seine reise nach
kia für zeigen wie wichtig für olaf
scholz frieden in europa wirklich ist
paul ronzheimer mehr zugeschaltete außer
kiew dort wo heute nacht paul auch
wieder die sirenen heulten paul lasst
uns uns zunächst über das interview mit
den klitschko-brüdern sprechen wir haben
ganz klare erwartungen formuliert in
deutschland ganz klare erwartungen was
jetzt passieren muss was gab es wird
olaf scholz diese erwartungen erfüllen
er kann nicht mit leeren händen kommen
oder schleuse deutsche bundeskanzler
kann ganz sicher nicht mit leeren händen
kommen praktiziere ich bin jetzt wieder
seit zwei tage hier zurück in der
hauptstadt und kate und nicht nur wenn
man mit den klitschko-brüdern spricht
oder mit der politischen elite des
landes sage ich mal sondern auch wenn
man hier auf der straße unterwegs ist
mit den bürgern spricht mit denjenigen
die diesen krieg hier aushalten müssen
seit monaten auch mit denjenigen die
nicht geflohen sind die ganze zeit hier
waren sie sagen alle wann kommt endlich
das was wir aus deutschland brauchen was
unbedingt da sein muss und da patricia
ist die frage kanter die ukraine zu hohe
erwartungen oder können wir diese
erwartungen tatsächlich erfüllen das
wird die große frage des besuchs seien
oder scholz kommt ja nicht alleine
kommen mit dem französischen
staatspräsidenten in meinem balkon und
dem italienischen regierungschef mario
tragen und das sorgt natürlich noch
einmal für eine ganz besondere
erwartungshaltung drei staatschefs drei
regierungschefs hier in der ukraine und
gleichzeitig die sorge was wollen die
wirklich wollen die möglicherweise blöde
mütze lenski den ukrainischen
präsidenten dort an einen tisch bringen
wollen sie druck machen dass er
verhandelt aller im osten gerade so
dramatisch verliert das sind ängste die
ist ja auch patricia
gleichzeitig in diesem interview paul
auch etwas formuliert was vielen schon
einmal durch den kopf ging und dort wird
das so formuliert der liebe gottes putin
zurücknehmen ganz konkret der tod
gefordert von vladimir putin
das ist das was vitali klitschko gesagt
hat man kann es so formulieren dass sich
viele in der ukraine seinen tod wünschen
das ist etwas was fakt ist egal mit wem
man spricht vielleicht muss man es ein
bisschen relativieren entweder dass er
die truppen zurückzieht dass er aufhört
damit dieses land als geisel zu nehmen
patricia mittlerweile fast jede familie
kennt jemanden der gestorben ist in
diesem krieg hunderte jeden tag 800
kilometer hier von kiew entfernt und
wenn man dort mit den menschen an der
front spricht mit den soldaten die wir
immer wieder begleitet haben da sagt man
uns wir sind hoffnungslos unterlegen
momentan artillerie der wussten ist
gewaltig wir haben dem nichts
entgegenzusetzen und vor allem es fehlt
an munition und natürlich wünscht sich
dieses land dass dieser grausamen krieg
endlich aufhört über drei monate bei
vier monate dauert es und es sind die
toten die daran erinnern es sind die
tausenden verletzten aber natürlich ist
dieses land nicht mehr so wie es vor dem
krieg war und das wollen die menschen
ist es sommer hier es wäre so ein
schöner tag aber diesen landesweiter
krieg er kriegt ihr einfach nicht
aufhört und der krieg der auch an die
deutsche tür klopfen könnte auch so
formuliert im interview mit der paul
welches szenario wird da gezeichnet
vitali klitschko sagt dass am ende
lade mir putin eben nicht nur die
ukraine will und das hat putin ja
zuletzt in einem interview auch deutlich
gemacht damals ging es um schweden zum
beispiel aber einem russischen
propaganda sendern ist auch immer wieder
von polen die rede vom baltikum also das
könnte dann ein nächster schritt sein
wenn man erfolgreich ist in der ukraine
wird man jetzt im osten erfolgreich ist
dann weitergeht hier richtung kräfte das
hat wieder linken spur auch gesagt kraft
ist weiterhin in gefahr wladimir putin
wird es wieder versuchen und dann so
seine analyse wird er weiter versuchen
das ehemalige sowjetische territorium zu
erobern und da sagen die ukraine das
betrifft dann am ende auch deutschland
nicht nur bei der nato frage sondern und
das wurde in der vergangenheit immer
wieder mal diskutiert auch der ehemann
die ehemalige ddr und gleichzeitig voll
gibt es immer wieder auch forderungen
gedanken welche zustehen zugeständnisse
die karine machen könnte damit es
endlich zu einem waffenstillstand kommt
diese diskussion natürlich jetzt auch im
vorfeld des längst überfälligen besuches
von olaf scholz wieder entflammt welche
zugeständnisse siehst du dort überhaupt
die möglichkeit bereich
ich sehe momentan kaum möglichkeiten von
der ukrainischen seite vertritt er das
muss man ehrlich so sagen die gab es mal
da ging es um dinge wie neutralität
nato-mitgliedschaft das glaube ich wäre
alles verhandelbar sogar während dinge
verhandelbar wenn man an die linie vor
dem 24 februar zurück denke also das ist
momentan die forderung die russen sollen
sich dorthin zurückziehen bevor der
große krieg begann auch da hatten sie ja
schon teile des dort wasser oberteile
von lohans erobert aber man sagt in kiew
dahin müssen sie zumindest zurück dann
kann man verhandeln nur auch da muss man
ehrlich sein das ist kaum realistisch
momentan russland die russische armee
wird sich kaum aus mario pohl zum
beispiel zurückziehen deswegen ist es so
wahnsinnig kompliziert hielten eine
verhandlungsmöglichkeit hinzubekommen
und die ukraine sagen moment mal gesagt
wir wollen nicht verhandeln wladimir
putin will seit zwei jahren mit unserem
präsidenten mit würde müsse ja nicht mal
telefonieren also es liegt nicht an uns
sondern an russland das ist die sicht
hier in der ukraine paul ronzheimer
vielen herzlichen dank mit informationen
aus kiew an diesem wunderschönen
sommertag auch dort wo sich die menschen
nichts sehnlicher wünschen als endlich
frieden danke